[Musique]
il est 5 heures le salon s'éveille dans
quelques heures la foule déambulera dans
les larges vallées
célestin et ses amis sont déjà la tâche
première mission de la journée nettoyez
les box et laver la quarantaine de
vaches dont ils ont la responsabilité
eh bien on n'est jamais bien en avance
on se fixe une aire pour être dans les
temps au niveau de l'ouverture du salon
et c'est toujours pas passé arriver
elle vient me m
allez
ces destins vinci parcourir plusieurs
kilomètres pour acheminer les vaches une
à une au point douche
le bruit du périphérique ce mélo
beuglement des bovins alors de moins
c'est l'embouteillage sur cas d'offre
rentrée placée on avait souvent comme là
on met deux bêtes des questions
n'avaient on en ramène de la plateforme
se veut pas prendre la porte et surtout
avec les taureaux
cela fait quatre ans que ces destins et
soigneur pour la race charolaise
le jeune agriculteur de 21 ans a grandi
avec les vaches au sein de
l'exploitation familiale
un patient chaque année de retrouver
l'ambiance du salon
ils participent à ce grand rendez vous
avec beaucoup d'implication
le matin de les nettoyer les curés les
maîtres propres
après de leur donner à manger
horatio d'habitude pour pour leur
changer ensuite
les peigner un peuple soit baby jolie
pure est très présente à moi là les
visiteurs
moi j'adore ça j'aime beaucoup les
vaches les animaux l'ambiance des
concours c'est vraiment plus un autre à
sa gamme on voit d'autres animaux
énormément de monde
que ce soit dans la race charolaise
comme dans tant d'autres races et ça
c'est vraiment super intéressant est
super cool
[Musique]
parmi les tâches quotidiennes d'un
soigneur il y en a certaines plus
agréables que d'autres la tétée des
veaux fait partie de celles-là deux fois
par jour l'équipe de ces destins ramène
des veaux à leurs mères respectives
on va à force de les voir
on les reconnaît facilement et et puis
bah ce que j'ai fait naître c'est encore
plus facile de la fenêtre
et pour un très bon les fenêtres vitrées
dès qu'on les voit une fois avec la mer
et tout ça les propriétaires
les poneys rapidement et facilement les
petits les petits bébés qui grossissent
très vite et tout ça c'est super
intéressant et court vers leur maman on
n'a même pas besoin de les emmener ils
diront tout seul donc c'est vrai que
c'est 100 et même drôle c c'est vraiment
intéressant puisse apprécier du public
ah oui oui généralement elles public
qu'ils adorent ça
les
il est 19 heures
la journée s'achève pour les visiteurs
mais pas pour les soigneurs ce soir une
vingtaine de bêtes vont prendre la route
pour rejoindre leur exploitation le
début d'un petit marathon pour ces
destins et son équipe continuent et les
charges et les autres bêtes
ensuite il y en a d'autres qui
reviennent donc on va procéder après au
déchargement et céréales y mettre en
place placer des animaux dans les
stalles et puis s'assurer que tout va
bien se passer
sony heures ces 24 heures sur 24 voilà
c'est ça on peut dire ça oui après on
essaye de prendre du temps pour essayer
de dormir après quand même parce qu'une
dix jours c'est long
[Musique]
il est deux heures du matin lorsque
l'équipe termine sa mission quelques
heures de sommeil et le jeune soigneur
entamera une nouvelle journée
plongez dans l'effervescence du salon